hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the curse
of Blackwater now someone wrote me a
very kindly worded email that went as
follows mark is so stupid how could you
be so dumb you know that you need to
keep running from the little girl and my
god
look in every drawer so thank you mister
sir for writing such a nice letter to me
um he also informed me that the little
girl you run away from until she goes
away and the second monster and
apparently there's a second monster you
hide from which I don't know how to do
because I can't even crouch but anyway
we're back to where we started before
and hopefully we won't die again lovely
room this boy I like it creepy music box
anyway they said to make sure to check
all of the drawers which I'm going to do
and I've already done I've already
checked every single room in the entire
place once over because the girl I don't
want did that happen before I don't
remember that okay alright just got a
kick in the balls reminding me that this
is actually a creepy game this is a
really really creepy game by the way
I've forgotten what it's like to play a
scary game without doing commentary it
actually is much worse because you know
you don't have anyone to talk to even
though I'm only talking to myself but
I'm not crazy okay maybe I am one jeez
their objective completed hooray hooray
medicine yay okay I don't see anything
here which means that there's absolutely
nothing I've checked all the drawers
hi little girl how are you doing you
doing good good I'm glad
so now that we're hearing that to this
point I must say I don't know what I'm
supposed to do because I've been in
every single room already and I didn't
find any other keys I don't think that
that was here
hey they here that I needed I checked it
almost every single drawer that there is
to check oh what the hell
I ripped that door right off its hinges
why why did I do that and there's got to
be something in this room that I have
missed because if there isn't then I'm
going to be in a lot of trouble because
I have no idea what else to do
had to be something here I've literally
I made absolutely sure that every single
one of the other drawers was opened and
I checked it thoroughly before I got it
hi how are you little girl you want a
juice box look at Teddy Bear there's
nothing else there's nothing here and
she's right across that door alright so
I don't know what I'm supposed to do but
I guess I'm just gonna be wandering for
a bit huh you guys don't mind did play
the music box auntie bumble II don't
hey buddy mommy moving I used to have a
little music box here that did the same
thing actually wait okay what am i doing
oh sorry sorry sorry okay
so I've a thoroughly ran my battery out
of light I have no idea where I'm going
and I think I creeped out my audience to
the point where they're gonna
unsubscribe to me okay I don't care I
care I care so deeply all right you guys
know I love you to death I'd be nothing
without you and that's a fact just get a
little sappy and emotional before things
go to hell the plus side of being able
to go around to everything and trying to
find what I need is the fact that I have
plenty of batteries in medicine don't
know what the medicine is for cuz she
insta kills that's what she does was
there something that I missed
I don't think so I've been through all
of this all of this already these doors
are locked there's some crowbar herbal
doors on the right side or the left side
depending from the entrance from the
lair really left side all these doors
are locked
I have no idea where to go what the hell
I just got jerked around there a little
bit hi don't mess with me you don't know
who I am or what I'm capable of I gotta
find a way to get into this other area I
think that they'd be the same whoa when
did this door open
say what okay dokay how about in here
anything in here I don't know when that
door up that was a battery give me that
I don't know when this door opened ah
yes
sweet God storage key on the best on the
best there ever was
ah to write down boat oh please over dad
oh god no okay good it's not I thought
he was gonna kill me I'm more concerned
about the progress that I would lose yay
what did that door open I have no idea
but I don't care she was right there man
right there
alright let's forget that ever happened
push delete that from a memory okay hear
that close these doors oh I ripped it
off its hinges again she's gonna come up
on me I'm gonna be trapped in here I'm
gonna die
gimme gimme what is that H bar it's not
like a crowbar but for H I don't don't
care are you down there lady are you
down there down there I don't see you
see you okay we're okay we're okay still
don't know what about as it does Oh care
got an H bar hopefully an H bar is
better than the crow but yeah yeah suck
on that
oh there we go finally Jesus trying to
close the damn door don't be a minute
sir where are you little girl I'm more
concerned that I don't see you
oh crap cause you are don't rip it off
thank you
okay anything over here I don't think so
fab yeah shout all day did you better
than oh oh
no you're gonna god I didn't murder a by
my niblets you hang me string me up
you're gonna do something I see your
hand how do I get on us
what do I do I'm gonna die she's just I
didn't even need to go in this bathroom
I'm gonna die I've got to die I'm gonna
die okay all right
balls to the wall I'm Eddie I go a
little girl you're so stupid
ha ha ha ha ha she's gonna kill bait day
to get our ride she can rip doors right
off their hinges and apparently so can i
all right come here
come here little girl you come this way
long way around I've got a key to
somewhere don't know where but I'm gonna
find the end mommy
I'm on I'm at me okay no no suck it up
markiplier your man
manly man got to find a way out of here
you're locked wrong door it's okay all
right I'll get trapped all right look
dude a lot - what is that what's that
sound what was that sound
pick it up third another Vale
productivity of a group of batteries I
don't know don't know why I said don't
care I feel like we're in trouble
that second monster might be right
around the corner aha library key oh god
don't be ruin their core okay we're okay
yep don't rip it off [ __ ] it's just so
strong I can't control my strength guys
I just can't do it I'm too strong way
too strong
sometimes being as pro as I am is a
considerable I didn't mean to do so
close it yet oh no oh no oh no what did
I do
up a research lab operator clap did I
make it to a checkpoint I'm on the verge
of a great discovery why is there a
research lab in the maternity hospital I
feel a terrible feeling in my spirit but
I'm so pro and amazing but I will not be
stopped by little stone with no girls or
the research labs suddenly I've turned
into Santa no soon to be a delicious
dead body I mean dead body over her
better find out what he's saying oh hang
on pick up things 15th of December entry
5 we have made a horrible error the
portal opened as we expected however
these monstrosities came through they
slaughtered us my colleagues the mothers
children they showed no mercy I'm the
only survivor I've sealed off the
blasters using my security code that
should keep them locked in I'm bleeding
out please whoever finds this note you
must close the portal find six security
guard sacks to access the lowered
research labs then flood the sewers
it would cause a fusion battery to go
critical and close the portal do not
open the blast door it must remain
sealed at all costs we cannot escape
whisk these beings escaping you got a
Brougham don't go I wasn't thinking of
opening them that wasn't my first plan
okay can't go back
I am trapped still need to know why I
have medicine and why that little girl
wanted to kill me in the first place
that's what I want to know and now don't
look well it's hardly fair don't tell me
I need to go back because I'm not going
back you can't make me go back let's see
maybe I need to pick it off of his dead
corpse hey mister you got a key on you
anywhere you got a key
got a light
well I don't see what I need to do here
at a horrible error stop Billy stop
those are puncture wounds stop you made
a horrible error got a battery
accidentally replace the battery like
immediately after I place another one
before so I'm down one more than I
should be
aha here we go key got it nailed it
all right who's Pro me cell 5 all right
carrying on let's see what we've got
waiting for us behind this door well
this looks good nice ergonomic keyboards
nice chairs some security monitors of
sorts and a big old switch that probably
opens up the doors that I'm not supposed
to open oh wait this is a bad idea
oh okay that just pop No whoa this is a
bad idea what is that is that a
Necromorph put a bucket put it again put
a big n I don't want to let it out I
wanted to put it back in
I just did what that guy said I
shouldn't do well I was stupid
I look dumb
I've made a horrible error I did exactly
what he told me not to do hello evil
monsters I want to rip out my donut run
aah
don't like right in my ear
very loud horrible
hey what am i doing now can I close that
door got some radioactive something or
something's where am I going ha ha
all rights that look definitely like a
Necromorph did we open a portal to the
dead space universe the scary part of it
because that's where all the scariness
went out of dead space I put it all in
this game
okay sack up markiplier ten to go one of
six key cards alright hope I haven't
missed one cuz I wasn't exactly looking
for them so another key card okay yeah I
hear that
I hear you I hear you I hear you
I can't exactly Crouch so let's just
leave the top of my head poking out from
wherever I'm standing what the hell is
that thing that a lamppost that sounds
close don't rip the doors off the hinges
you douche hey look we're stuff what I
need I hear heavy breathing ah locker
key good
wonder why that's in the urinal but no
matter it sounds close damn it
other bathrooms lock why this isn't fair
just give me what I need give me what I
want what I really really want don't you
give me what I want what I really really
want what I really what I really what is
that it that
but that's a security post but it's way
too small what the hell is that gonna do
I don't know don't not gonna ask
questions just gonna move forward be
awesome and live life - oh if on another
key card yeah that's what that key went
to once again that sounds extremely
close
I just sang but a baguette well no I had
a Carter that is exactly a Necromorph
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die that is that
is a Necromorph that is what that is
yeah I know
go away please did I win did I won oh
god I don't know give me light to be
light give me light yep yep this is bad
I'm now board the USG Ishimura coming to
you live from beautiful Santa Monica
what are the baby cribs doing over here
what do you wanna say to them Johnny you
seemed like people were running
psychotic experiments alright I'm
actually running out of time for this
part and I have a feeling I'm gonna die
so I'm gonna charge headfirst into the
monster limb to kill me just to see what
happens
just say yes there's a little bit what
can happen ha ha ha oh you look so
stupid oh you look so dumb hi are you
dick yeah let me
okay
so that looked definitely like a
Necromorph but at least you can survive
running away from them that's awfully
nice and that's what the medicine is for
so let me just see to make sure I
restart where I think I'm gonna restart
yeah buddy
all right so I better through a
checkpoint and I'm doing good so no one
can say that I'm not
hahaha okay so anyway thank you all so
much for watching thank you for your
tips it helped me got to this point and
if you wanna wait what am I saying
play the game link in the description so
thanks again everyone for watching it as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
Jenna
ah
that I
blood
Oh
you